more than 100 million people in the U.S
are experiencing record high
temperatures heat waves are creating a
higher demand for electricity and
straining the already aging U.S electric
grid increasing the risk of blackouts
here's how renewable energy sources like
solar could help maintain the grid and
at what cost a customer-led revolution
to solar and storage is the ultimate
fastest solution to climate change and
to the grid demands of the future
Mary Powell is the CEO of Sunrun a
company that provides residential solar
Services solar on the customer's rooftop
is interconnected with the grid so when
the customer's home and using a lot of
energy it is by definition supporting
the energy need that is going on right
there and when they're not it is Flowing
right onto the grid as an energy
resource to support the grid
solar panels paired with home batteries
can be even more beneficial because the
excess energy stored during the day can
be sent back to the Grid in the evening
as solar production goes down and this
energy storage can also be used to
prevent the power grid from breaking
down during extreme situations like a
heat wave
it is stunning to see this heat wave
that is gripping the United States now
it can really be the difference between
the grid functioning or not during some
of these significant climatic events
that create incredible stress on the
grid
the U.S department of energy said solar
is the fastest growing clean energy
source in the country compared to wind
water and nuclear power
but despite its steady growth solar
power comes with limitations on how well
it can perform and how much it can
actually support the grid
over time it will not produce as much as
it did initially and so when we work
with customers what we always build
around is an expected term of you know
25 years
residential solar panels degrade on a
median rate of 0.5 percent a year a drop
in efficiency means less solar energy
traveling back to the grid to help out
in times of need
it also means customers will have to pay
more for their utilities over time or
pay a steep price to get the panels
replaced
temperature can also affect the panel's
efficiency several solar panel providers
stayed on their websites that output
efficiency decreases with extreme
temperatures
and even though solar power is
considered a type of green energy what's
really cool is yes this energy source
requires materials it it does not
require fossil fuel
materials used in the panels such as
lead and cadmium can be toxic
as demand increases solar companies are
engineering new technology to better
adapt to extreme weather conditions
rooftop solar is just one of the many
Technologies experts say will be needed
to help support the grid
I knew we were never going to be able to
scale in time to meet the demands of
climate change without you know the kind
of innovation and and technological
solutions that come with a more
distributed Energy System